We've already seen that square roots can be expressed equivalently with either
radical signs or with exponents of one half, but as a matter of fact, all
exponent of 1 over n, where n is a natural number, can be expressed with a
radical sign But we need to differentiate between this radical sign and this
radical sign, or all the different radical signs we would use as this number n
changes. To do this we put a little number next to the radical sign. To denote x
to the 1/3 or the cube root of x, for example, you put a little 3 by the radical
sign.
The question I have for you is, if we want to express the nth root of x, what
symbol belongs next to the radical sign?